Britain a land of green pastures tea
drinking and centuries of political
stability until now not in my lifetime
have we seen anything like this
collection of public body language
British politics is broken
utterly broken the British people are
heading to the polls for the fourth time
in five years to try to break the
deadlock over how to leave the European
Union but this election is unlikely to
heal Britain's divided politics before
the brexit referendum Britain had
enjoyed decades of relative political
stability with one of the Conservatives
or Labour almost always in power but
their success was built on increasingly
shaky foundations one study found that
British voters trust in government
suffered a long decline from 1986 until
2012 and two events in particular became
emblematic of that loss of trust
on Tuesday night I gave the order for
British forces to take part in military
action and disarm Iraq of its weapons of
mass destruction the Iraq war has been
enormous turning point because the Iraq
war was an example of the government
making big policy decisions and big
policy promises that turned out to be
wrong we said that we had to have the
Iraq war because of weapons of mass
destruction those weapons of mass
destruction have never been found and
then a few years later the elite
appeared to be proven wrong again
the financial crisis of 2008 challenged
the competence of Britain's ruling class
the same people told us that we wouldn't
have a financial crisis that boom and
bust was finished they were clever
enough to control these financial
markets these experts proved to be wrong
these two events began to undermine the
political center on which both Labour's
Tony Blair and the Conservatives David
Cameron had built their success what
happens under Tony Blair and David
Cameron was the triumph of what I call
the Davos elite which is basically all
parties having the same sort of policies
which were very Pro markets very
economically liberal very socially
liberal and what David Cameron did was
to make the Tory party more acceptable
to the centre by embracing social
liberalism and what Tony Blair did was
to make the Labour Party more acceptable
to the centre by embracing economic
liberalism and that was all that was
being offered the collapse and Trust in
this elite then gave way to active
revolt
Jeremy Corbyn the election of Jeremy
Corbyn as leader of the Labour Party
signaled a rejection of the ruling
consensus and a decisive shift to the
left Jeremy Corbyn is an economic
radical and he presented the most
radical manifesto in economic terms that
the Labour Party has ever presented I
think then in 2016 the public had their
opportunity to turn in the establishment
over announcement came just after 7 a.m.
[Applause]
[Music]
within three years Boris Johnson one of
the faces of the leave campaign was
leader of a Conservative Party that had
shifted clearly to the right the people
of this country voted to get brexit
Danny
so brexit is part of a much broader
breakdown of the governing political
regime in this country we have at the
moment a Tory party which is moving
towards a sort of populist nationalism
and a Labour Party which is very
left-wing you have to polarize parties
now that creates chaos in all sorts of
ways if Labour were to defy expectations
and take power the party's economic
policies alone would have profound
consequences they have an extremely
ambitious radical set of policies which
is to change entirely the economic model
of this country this country is a very
open economy very dependent on flows of
foreign capital and a lot of that
capital will take flight and a lot of
the policies that they want to put
through will traumatize big corporation
small corporations so we will have an
extremely traumatic period both on
foreign exchanges and domestically
if neither party ends up with the
working majority they're going to find
it harder than ever to form alliances in
Parliament
now they've vacated the center ground if
the Tory party almost wins that doesn't
quite win it won't have anybody to work
with because it's so far to the right
according to a Liberal Democrat or
Scottish nationals that they won't work
with them probably we would have a
coalition of the Labour Party plus the
Scottish Nationalist Party plus the
Liberal Democrats very broad and rather
chaotic coalition such a coalition would
legislate for a second grexit referendum
[Applause]
a solid conservative victory would spare
the country through this fate but don't
expect Forrest Johnson's promise to get
brexit done the smellin ends to chaos
either Horace has promised to do this
extraordinary thing which is getting a
trade agreement with the European Union
by the end of next year that's really
not gonna happen it was too much to do
in time it might lead to a New Deal
breakfast where No Deal breaks it is
extremely disruptive and brexit could
mark the start not the end of the
country's constitutional turmoil
I think we've never been as close to the
breakup of the United Kingdom Boris
Johnson has negotiated a deal with the
European Union which essentially creates
a border down the Irish Sea and that
means that Northern Ireland is separate
in certain very significant ways from
the rest of the United Kingdom and is
being dragged slowly into the orbit of
the Irish Republic so that means that
the unification of Ireland in the long
term is brought nearer for Scotland who
voted to stay in the EU another
independent vote is already on the cards
so the Scots nationalists whenever they
make a speech in Parliament make a
speech about we voted to stay in but
you're taking us out against our will
and so we no longer want to be part of
this this kingdom Scotland has been
totally and utterly shafted that's
boosted support for Scottish
independence because remainders think
that the only way that they can remain
in the European Union is to vote for a
separate Scotland more and more you've
got pressure to break up the Union
whatever the outcome of the election
there's another reason why neither of
Britain's potential prime ministers will
end the chaos the economy is not growing
very fast the average worker has seen
their wages stagnate for at least a
decade
how do you get more growth and how do
you make people who felt left out of the
system feel more incorporated and both
parties have come up with solutions the
problem is that neither of these
solutions is likely to work
the Labour Party solution is too
ambitious it's too anti market and the
Boris Johnson approach of brexit plus
investing in public services all
economists agree that brexit will mean a
big hit for the economy and if you're
not generating more growth you can't
spend the surplus that you have on
public services so both parties are
asking very very fundamental questions
and both parties are giving you the
wrong answer to those fundamental
questions don't expect their answers to
change anytime soon
in part because neither party is likely
to return to the political center
anytime soon Britain could face a future
swinging between very right wing and
left wing governments and with no end in
sight to the political chaos thanks for
watching if you would like to follow
more of our coverage of the UK election
then please click on the link opposite
and if you would like to watch more
films like this then don't forget to
subscribe see you next time